on every September 11th I'm reminded
that flight 93 was the bravest act I've
ever seen but it's more than that it's a
lesson that teaches you how to deal with
all challenges how does an amazing
selfless act 16 years ago help you now
well what have you thought about their
heroic response to terror in times when
you are experiencing hardship look I'm
not saying that foiling a hijacking and
saving thousands of lives maybe even the
president is like breaking a leg or
getting food poisoning but that's the
point it relegates all challenges to
their appropriate place in the universe
and then on top of it it gives you a
model response for all of them let's
roll it's the perfect mindset against
fear in pain and it works anywhere it's
a fact you can't hold more than one
thought in your head go ahead try to pay
attention to two thoughts right now you
can't do it when you're faced with a
stressful event we feel we fill our
heads with just one thing and that's
fear it's in charge but it shouldn't be
they should so when you're faced with
something daunting what if you simply
thought about the passengers of flight
93
don't rely on yourself for inspiration
go to them thinking like 93 obliterates
the prison of your ego you get over
yourself
so 9/11 isn't about never forgetting
it's about using it to forget yourself
turning their powerful act into a
powerful tool to grab when times are
tough for you
let the souls of flight 93 help you
their assistance is eternal their gift
to you Lord knows we could use it
it sounds really shallow
maybe Dana but I do think when I'm
anxious I think about this that's on
shallow at all I think it sounds smart
so last September I got to go to
Shanksville and I hadn't had a chance
before even when I worked for the
president and it was very emotional and
I can understand why other this.y vice
president pence choked up today I
imagine that he had probably just gone
through the exhibit and in the exhibit
you have the opportunity to pick up the
phone receiver and listen to several the
phone calls that were made from
passengers on that flight here's another
thing about how
remarkable they were Greg they voted
right so it was that yeah there was
chaos and there was but they took a vote
and which is probably the absolutely
most American thing that you can do and
let's roll as you said that reminded me
of my favorite bible verse is only two
words it is fear not so it is a your
message is very good about how on 9/11
it's like that's the longest day ever
the day that never ends and there's
before 9/11 and after 9/11 and after
9/11 you actually have something like
the passengers of flight 93 to give you
a sense of bravery yeah edge yeah just
Kimberly ie it's not to diminish any
other acts of heroism that day I just
feel like there's a message here about a
mindset of knowing you're doomed and
you're gonna do the new and you're gonna
go and you're going to fight and you
know that you're gonna do good I mean it
to me it's a so symbolic of but you know
the American Dream and fighting for what
you believe in solidarity coming
together being fearless in the face of
evil and adversity and deciding to come
together for the greater good for the
possibility to save lives and untold
even further tragedy than one
experienced by this set by this country
by people being brave and sacrificing
themselves I mean really there is no
greater sacrifice there is no greater
honor or commitment that you could make
to your country and to those but people
that you don't even know but you share a
common bond and unity you know as
Americans and people that you know love
and cherish this country and said listen
we're going to do something about this
we're going to take ownership of this
and we're not gonna let them you know
have their way and God bless them it's
very touching why do you worry that you
know it's been 16 years and with time it
just wears away memory people move on
they don't think it because we haven't
had anything that devastating we've kind
of let her down our guards down or well
you know what I was remember being
struck by the period right after 9/11 so
it's a 16 years ago Greg that no matter
where you went there were flags red
white and blue and um people were so
proud to be an American people did not
hesitate to say you know what I know
which side I'm on I'm standing with the
Americans here
and you saw that globally in addition
and today by contrast 16 years later
it's not simply that there's so many
young people who you say really don't
remember it's that even among us as the
adults in the room there's so much
division and so much of the kind of
constantly harping at each other and
maybe this goes back to you know
focusing on things that are small but
nonetheless give you the opportunity to
skewer somebody right stick your finger
in say you were an idiot or some as
opposed to saying hey wait a second I
know what counts you know I
anybody who's ever been overseas for all
the back-and-forth that we have as
Americans you go overseas there's no
question you're an American people see
you as an American you feel it you miss
home all of the stuff that we take for
granted and on that day I remember you
know being in DC I remember being in
fear because people were worried as the
Vice President was saying not only about
the plane that we heard that was headed
towards the Capitol but that there were
subsequent attacks then planned for the
State Department and for other areas and
my son was in a school right across from
the Pentagon President Trump today spoke
about a policeman at the Pentagon who
rushed in and saved 20 people this to me
is America at its best in terms of the
response what came afterwards arguments
about the war the Patriot Act all that
even that to me is important but I do
lament the idea that 16 years later some
of us can't even talk pet Sammy's crazy
we're Americans Jessie last words and
whatever you want
I mean flight 93 makes me just so proud
to be an American to learn your plane is
a weapon and it's on a suicide mission
by Islamic kamikazes and then to then
rush the cockpit and do hand-to-hand
combat with guys with box cutters and
then wrestle the yoke away and then down
the plan to survive it's incredible it
was the first time the enemy really saw
the bravery but it wasn't the last and
you know there were a lot of heroes that
night or that day and that was because
they were united on United flight 93 it
wasn't just you know one single person
that went and took the plane down it was
people that United from all races and
creeds and colors
take the plane down because the
terrorists they don't care if you're
black or white or whatever you're an
American and they don't discriminate
so with terrorists only see us versus
them and I think we need to rise up and
say you know what we're going to unite
and do this but we're so divided right
now because politicians and the press
prey on these divisions in order to
exploit hatred for money or for ratings
you have you and Tifa versus the Nazis
men versus women black lives matter
versus police and we've lost a lot of
unity in this country and I think you
know after 9/11 it kind of subsided but
now you have the Hurricanes coming back
around the same time as this anniversary
and it gives us an opportunity to say
you know we're all Americans let's find
that solidarity again let's try to
preserve that because there's going to
be more storms and more Wars that we're
going to face together all right